you know ross we were talking in the
last segment about news that you can
learn on instagram
yeah yeah and you learn something right
i learn a ton of stuff you know a lot of
people get their news on twitter
different platforms
i you know i love instagram for a
multitude of reasons but
i learned that the incredible artist
david hockney is bringing his latest
piece of
optimism art to the public in this
super innovative way okay he's created
this beautiful hopeful digital animation
of a bright sunrise and it will be
played on
huge billboards in cities around the
world
and it just is a really fun seamless way
to weave art
into our everyday lives and this is what
i love
about um you know some of the
possibilities
that may come out of what the last
year has brought us would this have
happened without the pandemic and
museums closing would
people say how do we experience art and
listen
going to art museums is not for
everybody and
some people think it's kind of bougie or
maybe i'm not into this or you know that
and also why is an art
museum so precious why do you have to
pay and go in
and make this whole ceremony about it i
see the argument on both sides i am a
museum goer i am an art obsessed
person i've traveled the world going to
museums but what i love
about this is the lack of preciousness
the lack of like you have to do it this
way this is
all about accessibility free
it doesn't cost anything it's just
creating beauty
i'm just i'm excited i hope more things
come about in the world
like this and i think it is because of
what we've been through people have
been forced to be innovative and you
talk about accessibility that's what
this is
you know i grew up in a farm town never
going to museums i always felt it was
for like fancy people you know it wasn't
until i was like
40 that i really went to a museum i
thought oh my god this is amazing
and so people literally walking down the
street not knowing they're going to be
exposed to this incredible art will look
up and maybe
they'll realize that art is for them
this to me is just a gift
awesome and it's all over the world i
love it